so it's not about putting on an act it's
about becoming a guy who is attractive
to girls through fundamentally changing
who you are and how you carry yourself
yeah
and i think by changing who you are well
i think that gets confusing to girls
because girls want like the guy to just
naturally get it and just be like oh why
does guys just not naturally get it but
the problem is the vast majority of guys
don't have a role model or someone that
makes them naturally get it so they're
confused in their 20s so their only
option is either stay an incel or learn
so i think the second is better than the
first right for sure so the uh the thing
the two extremes
are being an incel which is you just sit
in your on your computer in your mom's
basin all day is that if you're a guy
who's not naturally attractive to women
and you're not able to get a woman then
you can either keep being who you are
which hasn't worked for 20 years you can
keep trying that it's not going to work
either or you can change who you are and
become more naturally attractive yeah i
i think the the best way to get women in
general is to improve yourself
whether that's financially whether
that's physically whether that's
mentally whether it's working out in the
gym that's getting smarter that's
getting making them laugh making them
laugh okay
the men who do get women who are
attractive are usually not working on
themselves
because they don't need to that's not
true a lot of them who are just they're
attractive they've got the charm on the
first level they get they get the girls
why do you need to work on your
character go to therapy work through no
no no no no no no those guys just okay
with the exception of a few
guys do have to work out look good stay
in shape understand social dynamics like
like hit the gym make money you just
named all the physical things aren't you
did not name one single emotional thing
you just you went working out make the
money make the connections
one thing what emotionally what do you
mean making personality personal i'm
talking about personality i said
specifically social dynamics
okay but that's reading a room getting
along with people how to treat the
waiter how to treat the the valet guy
that's it's still social
emotional so fill me in on what's
emotional that a guy that would be
attractive to things that are empathy
being sensitive guys don't have about
what
that's
about
empathetic you just want a guy to just
you want a guy
to be a care bear
what no we're talking about like let's
say you have trauma with past
relationships trust
um you know what you're talking about
you need a guy just to [ __ ] listen
yes
for whatever [ __ ] reason the guy it
just feels the need to just talk at me
talk yeah when he like you know the most
like empathy i mean i don't know what
like i'm not even i'm not i'm not bsing
you i don't know what empathy you know
how i show empathy when nikki's talking
this is what i do
oh cool yeah because you're listening to
no because i actually um i'm interested
in what she has to say it's just this
empathy is like extending your
understanding making formulating a
sentence that's like listening some
people have a very hard time just
listening right but sometimes if they
feel like they can contribute something
viable then i don't want them to talk
out their ass i want them to listen to
what i'm saying if you got to think
about it and then come to me and they
say hey you know our conversation it
made me think about this like i also
don't want someone just to answer be
like oh it's okay like don't be like i
don't want a [ __ ] answer either i
don't want somebody who's so emotional
more emotional than me because that's
all shining because excessive empathy is
going to work against a guy
but you want a guy to listen to you and
absorb it right understanding
understanding but not the personality
traits that are actually attractive is
like being grounded being assertive
being dominant uh being confident uh
being a leader those are the traits that
will actually get a guy girl a little
bit of empathy is good but a lot of guys
already have some level of empathy and
they overdo it on empathy and they just
come off as weak and soft how do they
ever do it how do you overdo it it's
like the guy who's just like oh well i
didn't think she was ready so i just
like you know i just gave her a kiss on
the cheek and good night meanwhile the
chick was like super dtf oh okay got it
and that happens all the time oh god i i
do agree a guy has to be a little a
little you have to be a little ruthless
no well not ruthless
assertive is definitely the good word
yeah
what's the difference between ruthless
and assertive ruthless is like i'm just
gonna [ __ ] this [ __ ] and never call her
back ruthless i'm doing what i want and
i'm not reading your body language i'm
doing it well that's why i said a little
ruthless not over none over doing it
i don't like the word ruthless okay we
could call it like playing to win or
whatever okay but you'd like the word
assertive so let's go there with the
search
i i know what i want and i go after it
and so the guy should be
i agree with you look women don't want a
wimp like i want the guy to make plans
and take me out on a date and be in
charge
i don't want a guy to be like where do
you want to go um like that's so
unattractive to me like the guy should
be assertive ruthless is not the proper
word ruthless to me is like yo [ __ ] i'm
gonna pick you up [ __ ] you and then go
home okay like that that's pretty
ruthless yeah that's extremely rude if a
guy said that that would be the
definition of ruthless i mean and if you
actually went on a date with him then
that's your best but then but i might be
into that right that's also gonna be
like that hey [ __ ] i'm on my way just
put on the front and close my [ __ ]
then i'll take it home all right bye do
you know what that first day hey that's
a fetish for some people you know that
yeah
when i say ruthless i mean more like
he's gonna make sure [ __ ] happens so
meaning if you flake on him he's gonna
follow up he's not really gonna like
take a [ __ ] answer he's gonna try to
figure out what's stopping you he's
gonna go out of his way to make [ __ ]
happen what does it mean like violating
your consent or something like that
that's like excessively ruthless okay
all right so assertive it is assertive
it is there it is so even back to the
texting thing be assertive don't take no
for an answer to some extent to some
extent okay so if you like that clip
click right here to watch another or if
you want to watch the entire sauce cast
click right here
[Music]